JOHNSON LINE.
THE
LEAD PASS D
CRISP AND A LOT BETTER THAN WE
.
NULAND ARE DROPS IT.
THERE THE ACTION.
FIVE WILL HAVE TO DUMP YOU A LOE
SAVE HERE
AND TAVERA
IT IS THE TRANSITION BACK INTO
.
TO KUBALIK. PENALTY
BY KURASHEV.
TAKES THE SHOT.
I'M NOT SURE HE COULD UP
EVERYONE STOPPED.
THAT IS HOW THEY ENDED UP WITH
THE RUSH IN THPLAY.
MARNER FLIPS INTO THE CORNER.
CHICAGO..
HAPPY BIRTHD NOW.
WHERE YOU ARE TRADING CHANCES
AGAINST THE MAPLE LEAFS.  GOOD T
LANKINEN.
NOW RIELLY GETS IT BACK TOER.
THE GAME KUBALIK. S IN THE NHL.
AND THE LAST GAME HE PLAYED
AGAINST THE ISLANDERS CERTAINLY
DOWN TO 10.
DEFENSIVE ZONE POSITIONING.
GETTING YOUR ENTIRE ROSTER HAS
GONE.
THERE HAVE BEEN A COUPLE Pat:  H
THREE HERE IS THE LEAD PASS.
A BREAKAWAY CHANCE